so we've now learned of a child in iowa
who has died of coronavirus
complications and this was the first
death of a minor there
during the pandemic and meanwhile
schools are opening today
in iowa now there are schools in iowa
that
decided we're going to go remote for now
or at least they thought they decided it
because then the governor's
the governor of iowa came in and is
actually forcing some schools to open so
there's about three or four different
stories here one
is this is exactly why lots of places
try to make it illegal
or at least a violation of contracts for
teachers to go on strike
so that when the governor says jump
instead of saying
why are we jumping that doesn't make
sense they say how high
and this is exactly an example of that
it relates to collective bargaining it
relates to unions it relates to so many
different things on the labor side but
it's not our focus today the other side
of it
is really the craziness of of the
pandemic and the entire story of
opening and school openings and the like
and the really crazy thing about the
school starting fiasco
is that it's all becoming laughably
political and i want to be careful about
saying laughably because people's lives
are at stake here but what i mean is
it's obviously political
because we're now only talking about a
couple of months
it's just that they are months that are
crucial to donald trump's re-election
and possibly to the re-elections of
republicans in the house in the senate
gubernatorial republican reelections and
i'll explain
what i mean by that and be really
specific you have people on the right
like trump but many republican governors
although charlie baker here in
massachusetts has been good on this
republican senators you have all these
people saying open the schools now
open it for economic reasons open it for
mental health reasons you know being
closed
leads to suicides and uh mental health
issues and isolation and all of this
stuff okay
their gambit is schools being open will
help them get reelected particularly
trump
the idea being the optics of schools
being open
is good politically it'll seem like
things are returning to normal
in advance of the november election and
there is a truth to it there i don't
deny that there's an economic reality
here
where many parents can't work or can't
work
as much as they normally would if their
kids aren't in school because they're
essentially counting on school
for child care they are in jobs thanks
to our economy
that don't pay enough for them to be
able to say okay i'll pay for child care
and then go to work the numbers don't
make sense so
i'm completely sensitive to that and
these are real issues
i'm not brushing off the issue of
opening schools
as something that we shouldn't even
consider in some places
there are counties that have almost no
cases
and in particular there are these sort
of semi-rural schools where you might
have like seven through 12
might have 150 kids right 25 kids per
class
you can do that relatively safely and
i'm not against
doing that the problem is that's not the
case
in a variety of places that are opening
where we've
instantly seen cases spread quarantine
start etc
and again it's almost september at this
point we're talking about
one semester had we done it's always too
little too late
had we done a full coordinated shutdown
in the spring
two months maybe three full mass
compliance we would look like many
countries
which now are doing well and we wouldn't
be having this conversation to the
degree that we are having
it would be clear there's a bunch of
schools that can open
but now everything has to stay open
things the guidelines are ignored
schools must open and we're in a
position
where for political reasons donald trump
and others want to force schools open
and we saw what happened we looked at
georgia we looked at missouri
we're looking at iowa indiana everywhere
kids and teachers start getting sick
entire classes have to be quarantined
for weeks you're essentially ending up
sending a whole bunch of people home
anyway
it would be far more logical although
maybe not politically beneficial
to say let's do the semester remote
we're not saying no school
we're not saying no school for a long
time if things go well
we are hopefully hopefully just a couple
of months from some vaccine approval
optimistically
which by the end of the year some more
significant number of people will be
able to start getting
and in the spring semester things will
start to normalize
with it will still take time but right
now
the debate is over just a few months and
what is the real obstacle for many
parents it's the money piece
other countries have said let's be safe
and let's
really send people money and take care
of people
the long run benefit suggests it's
warranted
in the us it took months to get one
twelve hundred dollar payment
to people who knows if and when the next
one is going to come
and that creates this problem it's the
same with
the desire for many on the right to cut
the unemployment benefits
if you do that you're going to force
people back to work not safely
necessarily
but it will create a semblance of
normalcy so they will frame it as
the left wants everything closed forever
the left wants everything closed
until november 4th just to hurt trump
right one of these two
it's almost september we're talking
about like three months now just do
school from home
we'll get to winter break and then
hopefully by then
some portion of the population will
start to be vaccinated
we'll be starting to get beyond the
halfway point of flu season
we're all going to be better off without
having to reshut down because things
explode
that's disastrous economically flu
season coming
i got my flu shot friday glad to have it
dr fauci recently said this won't go on
forever
but we have to be safe until we get to
the other side and now iowa which opens
schools today
with the first confirmed child
coronavirus
death